[Music]
I'm really happy to see many people in
this room now even though this is the
morning session on the last day and
especially I see some really
enthusiastic people in the front row and
in this session I would talk a little
bit practical aspect of machine learning
projects so if you are actually working
on some real machine learning projects I
hope you will find something useful for
your project in this session okay anyway
I'm at Sigma Chi I'm a Solutions
Architect for Google cloud platform I'm
based in Tokyo and in this session I
will talk about the continuous
deployment in machine learning so what
does it mean the concept of continuous
deployment is fairly common today
especially in the field of web
applications so for comparison let's
think about the very traditional
enterprise business application project
in that case once you have successfully
launched to your initial version of the
of your business application it is
basically the end of the story
it's really happy ending of your project
however if this is a project of the
modern web application especially for
consumer users you know just reiation is
different because the requirement from
end users especially from consumer users
are always changing so to keep up with
the changing reality you have to keep
upgrading your application sometimes you
have to introduce new technology to
change your application completely so
basically you have to keep deploying new
versions of your application
forever this is a basic concept of
continuous deployment in web
applications and I'd say the same
concept can be what should be applied to
machine learning project so let me start
with explaining what continuous
deployment means
in machine learning project and this is
a very common imagination about machine
learning among many people I don't say
it's you but still many people believe
that machine learning is a magical
mathematical algorithm you have some
data you put those data into the
algorithm then you have magical result
of course it's in usual as you know the
leo machine learning project especially
the end-to-end process of machine
learning involves a lot of human efforts
first of all you have to collect your
training data and organize them with
some big data to like be query or Cloud
dataflow on GCP and then you need to
employ data scientist to build machine
learning model according to your
training data and then you use a bunch
of computing lasers like on crowd round
land machine learning engine on JCP to
train your machine learning model and
finally you can deploy the train model
to the leo world as an api service or
the Adhan and back in service from your
machine learning applications and the
good news is that you have a lot of
useful tools to support this end-to-end
machine learning process on gcp and i
think you have heard of these tools in
other sessions however in this session i
don't talk about these tools at all the
main focus of this session is about
feedback because the goal of machine
learning is to predict something in the
real world and as you know the Leo world
is always changing so you need to have
some feedback from the real world to
upgrade your machine learning model to
keep the freshness of your machine
learning model now the question is how
and why feedback was a freshness is
important in machine learning so let
use this very simple example to explain
why a freshness matters in machine
learning models this is a tutorial
article the title is machine learning
with structured data I published this
article this year so you can find this
article by searching with these titles
and in this article I explain how you
can build machine learning model to
predict baby's weight on the right side
of the screen using an example
application you specify some attributes
or plugin and person by clicking the
predict button you can make a prediction
about the newborn baby's weight babies
who will be born in near future like in
2018 or 2019 I think this model have
some realistic use case I believe some
doctors can use this machine learning
model for some medical purpose but
anyway in this article I use the open
public dataset code and Authority
they're set to train this machine
learning model it is available for
everyone on bigquery
it is best records in the United States
from 9 1969 to 2008 and it contains more
than 100 million records so in a sense
it is a big data it contains data for
nearly 40 years
very good but let's look at the snippet
of the sequel to extract our trend data
from bigquery as you can see the we're
close I didn't use a whole 40 years data
to train this model I used only data
after 2001 so what a problem with using
the whole data to train this machine
learning model and the answer is data
freshness because the goal of this model
is as I told you to predict baby's
weight who will be born in near future
in
2018 so naturally sinking using very old
data like incentives to train this
machine learning model may not be good
for that purpose because environment
surrounding people in 70s could be
totally different from today so I did
some experiment first I trained this
machine learning model with the data in
fairly old days like in 70s and then I
tested it against the relatively new
test data in 2008 and the lizard was
1.21 RMS error what does mean it means
the predictions of this model is
different from the ground truth
different from the actual value in
average 1.21 pounds is it good or bad of
course to understand it you have to
compare so then I tried the same model
with relatively new data from 2001 to
2008 and again tested with the same test
set in 2008 and the lizard was 1.05 RMS
error
so obviously this leads out is better
than the previous one that's the reason
why I used data only after 2001 to train
this machine learning model
very good make sense however this is not
the end of a story now suppose that I'm
really serious about using this machine
learning model in the LIA world I want
to provide this machine learning model
to real doctors in that case I have to
validate this machine learning model
against the latest data like in 2018
unfortunately the open natality date
said do not have the data in 2018
so I couldn't test it but naturally
thinking because this model was trained
with the data until 2008 that tesla's
out against 2018 test data might be
worse than the previous one so basically
if you are really serious about using
machine learning model in the real world
for the platica purposes you have to
keep collecting new data forever and
sometimes you have to lead train your
machine learning model with the fresh
data to keep the freshness of your
machine learning model so this is a
basic basic idea of the continuous
deployment in machine learning and the
next question is how you can apply this
concept in your machine learning project
what is a standard process of continuous
deployment in machine learning what is a
best practice so to explain that today I
prepared one two three three user
stories and the first two stories are
just imaginary one you may think these
are lily and natural situation
I admit it but at least I hope through
these imaginary stories you will
understand what is a standard process of
applying continuous deployment and what
is a value of continuous deployment in
machine learning and the last one is a
leer user story today I'm really happy
to invite cousin he's working for brain
part it is machine learning partner in
Tokyo he has a lot of experience of
managing real machine learning project
he will talk about his experience how
and why continuous deployment is very
important in his project how he applied
the continuous deployment in his real
project later okay but anyway let me
start with imaginary story and for this
story
I prepared a very simple example
application it is a handwritten digit
recognizer you can do some number on the
white canvas and by clicking the
prediction button the model recognized
what is what
number is very simple and now suppose
that there is a imaginary company the
CEO want to release this application to
the real world and make some money ok
and as a total we have two imaginary
stories the first one is very bad they
will make a silly mistake however the
important thing is to understand why
such a silly mistake had happened and
how they could have avoided it by
applying the continuous deployment okay
so let's start the first story please
welcome the CEO of the imaginary company
no listen on the stage hi nice to meet
you everyone
I'm nori so I've just started my new
company and I've created a super fancy
up using machine learning model but I
have a problem I'm not sure how much
data we should correct to train machine
learning model appropriately so my team
had worked very hard to correct the
initial set of the training data but I
still don't know if it's enough or not
so I hired a funky wannabe data
scientist
so it's Yahoo so fortunately he had a
brilliant idea to evaluate our machine
learning model so yeah boo breathe deep
please tell me the detail
hi everyone my name is yeah boo and I'm
funky wannabe the other side I like you
very with other things so to make
success in machine learning project I've
read super advanced machine learning
textbook and according to it you need to
split your data set to training data set
and test set you know
the first you should train your
machinery model with training dataset
and by date your model your a test set
so that new machine on your model will
not overfill to training your training
data actually I've already done it for
you and I got partial result we got
hundred percent accuracy here this is
super nice right this machine any model
as soon as possible to our application
so what do you think Marie oh my god I
can't believe it
[Laughter]
this application ok let's launch it okay
thank you know Lisa and Lisa you were
good performers now on surface they did
a very good job they achieve the
brilliant leaves out perfect accuracy
and of course they made a mistake so let
me show you what would happen if they
launched this application to the real
world can you turn to the demonstration
screen hello can you turn to the
demonstration okay this is a handwritten
digit recognizer they launched so let me
try I drew number zero make a prediction
okay it's working great
let me try number one it's strange
let me try number two okay
it doesn't work so I will tell you what
had happened and the covers so can you
turn back to the presentation okay this
is the data they used to train the
machine learning model and evaluate it
they have only the URLs so that's why
that model recognized everything add
zeros but at the same time they achieve
the perfect accuracy against this test
set some of you missing this is very
funny and realistic situation it is
partially correct and partially wrong I
can say that very similar thing could
happen in the leo machine learning
project as you know sometimes you think
you have a lot of data to try machine
learning model especially very complex
deep learning model appropriate Pedro
big data great and you achieve the very
good accuracy against the tested however
if those data do not reflect earlier
would it doesn't make any sense
it doesn't want work in the real world
so the question is how you can detect
such a silly situation how you can avoid
it how you can mitigate the situation
that is a continuous deployment so to
explain and to make the scenario a
little bit interesting out there some
assumption now suppose that they keep
collecting the data every day on the
first day day one they have just zeros
unfortunately but next day they have
zeros and ones next day on the Sunday
day three they have zeros ones and twos
so by keeping collecting new data every
day they come closer and closer to the
reality and all the fruit on the last
day on day ten they have a complete
dataset reflecting earlier war
completely so based on
this assumption let's see the next good
scenario they will apply the concept of
continuous deployment in your project
and they take the problem
I will mitigate the problem so now
please welcome the CEO of the imaginary
company no listen again on the stage hi
nice to meet you everyone I'm no real
gay so I've studied my new company again
I'll skip this part so anyway so
fortunately I could hire a super layer
data scientist this time
[Laughter]
it's yeah whoo ok so yeah what can you
tell can you do for me this time please
tell me
hi everyone again my name is Yabba and
this time I'm really the scientist so to
make a machine learning project success
I think we should several things to do
to keep the cruelty about machine and
model so let me show you some critical
action items here so to make success in
Mechelen project first you should define
your criteria criteria or threshold for
machine learning model in this case we
can say we can use the threshold as our
criteria and the 90% accuracy as a
threshold with such metric we can check
if the machine on Moodle works well or
not what good enough to deploy that to
real application and the second we
should keep collecting data so that we
have more and more Ambassador set that
reflect the real world and the last but
not least we should keep monitoring the
performance of the Machine and model so
that we can determine the timing of the
deterrent deployment and also retraining
available machinery model so today
actually to follow this
action items it's bit difficult in real
really real situation but today I want
to show you some pretty good - bow that
follow to follow these action items so
can you ask change to the demo screen
okay this is the data pant panel of the
dashboard so first let me our train
our machine line model with train data
set from day one since we will take some
seconds and to finish training let me
explain how to use dashboard so now you
can see the data set from day one to day
term but since this is a demonstration
setup you can see all the data set now
but suppose that in real situation the
data should be added every day and this
support that we are now on day one so
this is the situation where we are
training our machine on model with
latest data set so now training has done
I think yes so what is the next step and
addition says the next step is by data
or machine and model so let's switch to
the by Dacian panel of the dashboard
again you can see all the data set but
suppose that this is a demonstration
setup so let's assume that we are on day
one and the result is okay now 100%
accuracy so as we said 90 percent
accuracy as our threshold this hundred
percent accuracy is far beyond the odds
ratio so if you like you can deploy a
machine and model to your application as
an initial version but you know this
hundred percent accuracy is sort of
illusion
so do you can you guess what will happen
if you validate our day 1 machine model
with tester from day 2
let's see
as us-backed the accuracy is now going
down to around 45% so this is really bad
and far below the threshold so do you
know what why this happens yeah maybe
you already know so in day one dataset
there are only digits zeros but they too
dataset contains not only zeros but also
ones so that's why day one machine model
doesn't work well on day two dataset so
what should you do in next step yes the
next step is retraining your machine
animala
so now we are on the data panel and
start retraining
our machine model with training data set
from day two since it will take some
seconds again so this time let me
explain how to use the pro button here
so this deploy button lets you easily
deploy your machine on model to your
application so let's check how it works
in application window here so now we
deployed a day 1 machine model so this
machine line model can recognize digit 0
but as you may expect this model cannot
recognize digit 1 as like this so now
maybe your training is done so so what
will happen if we click the deploy
button on day 2 as you expect
so can you change today yes thank you so
now the application starts to recognize
digit 1 whoo yeah
so so this deep low button allows you to
not only deploy your machinery model to
your application but also rollback the
machinery model to your application so
implementing this kind of button or
command in your system is very feasible
and practical when you are driving a
real machine learning project anyway we
try we finished training the day to
machine and model the next step is by
dating our machine model with latest
test okay
now by later machine model which tested
from they - oh ok so now the accuracy is
recovered from 45 percent to 99 percent
this is really great and this accuracy
is far beyond threshold so you can now
redeploy your machinery model to your
application but Jamie's point will help
if we test this machine our model with
latest data set so now suppose we are on
day 3 so what will happen is the
accuracy yeah
rush accuracy again it's going down to
66 67 percent so you so in this case you
should again return your machinery model
with diverse data set actually in a
machine learning project you should keep
or continue this process forever until
you shut down your application well this
is very simple example but in summary in
real machinery project there are three
critical action items the first is
defining threshold and criteria of your
machine model and the second is a
continuous data collection and the third
is contained continuous monitoring with
those action items I'll help you to make
success in machinery project thank you
back to editing ok thank you everything
okay can you keep this cling on the
demonstration okay now they did a fairly
good job using this demonstration dust
roll so let's look back what does what
they have done on day one they turned
their machine learning model with the
day 1 data and tested against that are
tested from the same day the perfect
result and the next day they tested
again the same model with the latest
date tested from day 2 and they realized
that they had some problem the accuracy
is very bad but at least using this
monitoring tool they realized they had a
problem so they could take a action to
recover from it jelly transnational
model with our new dataset from day 2
and then they recover the accuracy to
99% very good and next day they tested
it again latest tested from the 3 the
accuracy became worse than again however
they can be trained the machine learning
model so using this kind of monitoring
dashboard
they clearly Erised they had a problem
that's a value of this monitoring so can
you turn back to the presentation as you
can see on the last day day 10 they have
10 machine learning models and they can
test against 10 data set from different
days there are 10 times 10 equals 100
combinations so just for experiment
I clicked all the validation button and
see the result it looks a little bit
complicated but for example let's look
at the first roll those numbers show the
accuracy of the model from day 1 Apple
entry the accuracy is going down
straight for three so if you if they
didn't have this monitoring - what
happens if they kept using this machine
learning model forever
it is a tragedy disaster so the lesson
is in a sense very simple if you don't
have this kind of monitoring tool if you
don't update your machine running model
with fresh data your model will be
obsolete divinatory and you can learn
one more interesting thing with these
numbers let's look at these numbers on
the diagonal right
this shows the recovered accuracy first
date they achieve the perfect leads out
next day they lick about accuracy to 99
percent on Sunday they recovered
accuracy to 98 percent interestingly
these recovered accuracy is also
slightly decreasing it looks like this
on the bar chart and as you remember
perhaps he said that he said the nine
percent accuracy as a threshold it means
they don't want to use a machine
learning model if the accuracy is less
than 90 percent in the sense they have a
problem on the last day day 10 the
recovered accuracy on day 10 is slightly
less than 90 percent it's a problem for
them they have to do something to
recover from this region so let him
explain for us why this slight
decreasing had happened it is a data
complexity as you know every day they
keep collecting new data they have more
and more complex data and if the initial
model was very simple it could handled a
very simple first day data but it may be
really hard for the simple model to deal
with very complex data from the last day
so basically what they have to do is
just redesign their machine learning
model if they are using neural network
they would add some more layers to make
the machine learning model more complex
to deal with more complex data so this
assembly of the flow on the top left
first you build your machine learning
model and a train with initial data and
you keep monitoring every day or every
week and if necessary you retrain your
machine learning model and sometimes you
recover the accuracy above the threshold
and sometimes you cannot leak about
accuracy even after the lea training in
that case it is a really good timing for
your project to redesign your machine
learning model you hire the layout data
scientist again they will do some
investigation about the nature of the
current dates that they will redesign
the machine learning model according to
the current dataset
ok now I think you have some basic idea
what is a process of the continuous
deployment and finally I will invite
concession from a machine learning
partner in Tokyo he will tell you his
real experience how he applied the
continuous deployment in his earlier
project please welcome Carson on the
stage
[Applause]
hi good shield
I'm cousin from rampart which is a GP
partner in Japan we have 80 data
scientists in Tokyo and we have
delivered a memory system for deaf in
destroyed burrito industry for madam
Tanya okay one of our customer case of
eqp was the future in Google Code of
next 70 QP is a manufacturer who the
product demon is very popular in many
countries they apply the machine
learning technology to detect part
potato cubes in their production line we
implemented a data system we don't tell
from for them ok let them back to the
main topic of this session I'd like to
talk about another customer case we are
we implemented a continuous environment
for machine learning systems I'd like to
explain why the continuous deployment is
so important for a male models
unfortunately the detail of this
customer case are confidential so are
there some essential aspect of
conscience to prevent what I learn from
history our case the customer is the
service provider they develop clients
product from the away houses to client
outreach so we help them to apply data
science and machine learnings to
optimize their delivery route and
minimize the delivery cost here is our
solution
first we implemented a machine learning
model which today's demand forecast for
each product using the data from the CRM
systems and then we apply another model
which calculates the best delivery route
based on this demand forecast
ok dude so due to the G system our
clients saves about two billion dollars
per year
so let's focus on the continuous
deployment of this demand the forecast
model
the diagram shows that the continuous
deployment of system of being our
clients case first we determine the
model in your weekly basis due to the
change in the market it is not possible
to use the same model modern week so we
introduced the training process in a
regular basis sometimes the performance
model is under the threshold even after
the training in such a situation
our aware engineers try to modify the
model itself to keep the model
performance well we generate Khandelwal
month's report which is about model
performance so our client can understand
what we are doing okay and this is the
process of this contains the parameter
in our clients and then she is have
details added to this explain the
freshness of the data is very important
to keep the model performance
well in this client case the CRM data
has a very strong personality and is
influenced by some other external events
so the returning with fresh data is very
good way to keep up with these changes
it is also important to monitor the
model performance by comparing demand
focused actual result in most case in my
experience this retraining process works
very well so it would be a good idea to
automate this repeatable processes but
sometimes it doesn't work leave after
draining that model per horse could be
very bad in such a station a mere angel
look into the
she RM data and other data sources to
find out what's happening in the real
market typically this kind of a
performance degradation is called a
drastic change in the input data it is
influenced by competitors promotion or
new product launch and so on after
finding good causes about the
distillation
engineer think about holiday commodified
about the future to keep up with these
changes as you can imagine this
investigation is very hard to
standardize but at least we are building
a dashboard to help amira engineers to
work on this investigation efficiently
follow me let me talk about the risk
management one of apparently is in this
process is that there is a novelty that
a mere engine can be covered of modern
performers in a timely manner there are
not to be a data products in our data
file a model cannot to make meaning
meaningful prediction for a while this
is a sort of nightmare scenario and we
should have a back-up plan for such a
station in this current case we define
the kind of fear background will cry as
in a very early stage of this project if
a male model doesn't work at all
our clients switch back to the manner
operation of course in this operation
there is no machine learning model and
then so at all our clients using the
Amanda forecast which is a flow human
plan now he used statistical approach to
make this demand forecast
okay this is what I want to talk to and
then I will talk so I will talk I was
not that the customer case of this is a
very simplified actually in my project
we have much more complex process and
the matrix but anyway the most important
thing in production environment is that
how quickly we can detect this kind of a
performance degradation and how quickly
we can fix it we are now planning
general building a general platform to
help every engineer of course it
streaming rain this kind of processes
English including monitoring the
training design the model and the
deployment so I will hold this this
platform will be used in many machine
learning project for our clients
thank you thank you guys
okay so sue his leer experience I think
you have some realistic image what is a
company continuous deployment in the LIA
project
so now as assembly let me talk a little
bit about the platform for the
continuous deployment as Carson told us
he's now thinking about designing some
standardized platform or general
platform for the end-to-end machine
learning including the continuous
deployment process and I think this is
Lily the frontier of the machine
learning project some customers and
partners earlier rising the importance
of the continuous deployment and most of
them are thinking about what is the best
process what is the best platform to
support that process and we Google is
the same recently released a paper
called tf-x it is a entering machine on
a platform used by Google internally
including the continuous deployment some
of our machine learning services are
actually learning on this platform
unfortunately this platform itself is
not an external service you cannot use
this platform as a as a non DCP service
but at least the good news is that some
essential components used in this tf-x
is available as a part of tensorflow
you can see this paper for details so in
theory you can combine tensorflow with
some standard DCP products and
components to build your own continuous
deployment platform and for today's
demonstrate demonstration i combined
tensorflow with some standard GP
components to build that demonstration
dashboard however please be careful
these specific components are not
important these are just for the sake of
demonstration
especially depending on the requirement
or obeah project functional or
non-functional requirements this
component could be different the
important thing is to understand the
general framework and I think most
end-to-end machine learning platform now
has three components on the bottom side
of this chart first you need some data
platform to collect the trend data from
the business data pipeline and then you
have some training platform like cloud
machine learning engine to train your
model with these training data and
finally you have some sobbing platform
to deploy the trainer
our machine learning model to the real
world however to liaise that continuous
deployment practice you need one
additional component that is a
validation platform on the top side with
this foundation platform you keep
monitoring the accuracy of your machine
running model and ideally this platform
have some visualization to with this
visualization you can understand the
trend of the accuracy of a machine
learning model and then figure out the
best timing to the train your machine
learning model work to lead design your
machine learning model by hiring dead
scientists again and also it should have
some automation mechanism like today's
demonstration just with a single click
you can lead to any a machine learning
model with just a single click you can
Li deploy your machine learning model to
the real world so this is the sort of
room for action if you're now working on
some realistic the our machine learning
project and want to apply the continuous
deployment in your project please let's
start have the discussion with your team
members to think about what is the most
important feature in New York continuous
deployment platform what is the best
monitoring dashboard for your project
okay in that sense I want to ask
additional question to counseling
because are you still here
thank you okay my question is that he
told us that now he's planning to design
his own machine learning platform
including the continuous deployment for
customers in his of his company so what
do you think is the most important
feature of the machine learning platform
for your customers okay the question is
a little bit complex for me so I'd like
to answer this question in Japanese okay
no problem I will translate sky Roxy
model all the shiny gamma let's go mo da
na sono Gilman not at all I took action
model we know Zuko come back with a
ponderous man unit a boom maybe I can
show that 32 car so no how kind of
timing good so just again to determine
on data pipeline do you know Mom Yama no
you're not gonna do tonight
no platform you know keynote pushed a
each even do you know platform giving
flow of your application don't know yoni
the sky rocks you monitor English they
don't constitute the network you know my
my audience and I cannot DiMaggio
another unit on Windows
sorry about my Japanese ok that's no
problem
I think he took a really important topic
so it's a little my challenge to
translate in accurately
ok basically he told me that the most
important thing in machine learning
project is to evaluate the performance
of the model in a Leo business context
using the Leo business data it means in
today's demonstration we simply tested
the trainer model against the test set
but in his project as he talked in his
presentation he compared the actual
business out of it against the models
predictions
so for that he needs to combine the
business data pipeline with a machine
learning pipeline because he needs a
very fresh business outcome data it does
make any sense if he evaluates a
performance our weeks or months later
ideally he must've evaluate the result
in your time with a layoff time business
data so the challenge is how to combine
these two platforms business platform
and machine learning platform so his
idea is he want his platform be capable
of integrated with business leader
pipeline with a machine running pipeline
I think now it is a very common
understanding that synchronizing
business data with machine learning to
collect our training data in a timer
timely model is very important but he
told me that it is also important to
synchronize the evaluation data from the
business data platform ok that that's
really a good lesson thank you very much
okay yeah it's surprising i Lili learnt
a new thing in this presentation from
Kansas on and I think it is leading
useful for your project - and
unfortunately I don't have much time to
talk about details more details in a Q&A
session but basically I'm really happy
to have further discussion in person
with you if you really like so this is
announcement today's afternoon we have
an event called naturally called cloud
hero this is a sort of DevOps
competition I'm not sure whether you can
still register in this event or not but
at least I will be there I will be
attending this event so if you want to
talk to me in person please find me at
the venue of this event in this
afternoon okay that's all thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
you